what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
mcu and today we have a really
interesting interview with tom holland
now the interview is about his upcoming
movie uncharted but of course he is
asked about spider-man no way home where
he answers a very important question he
actually clarifies something that he
said a little while back that a lot of
people have misunderstood and he says in
the interview that everybody seems to be
misconstruing what he said it is when he
said in an interview a long time ago
that if he's still playing spider-man
when he's 30 he is doing something wrong
he offers clarity for that in this
interview he then goes on to talk about
continuing to play spider-man and
passing the mantle on to possibly
somebody like miles morales or spider
woman and he even briefly mentions that
marvel and sony got a lot of good things
going on as far as ideas are concerned
so let's watch this interview and then i
also have some things that he said in
another interview about a really awesome
scene with andrew garfield and toby
maguire that i'll break down as well he
talks about how he loved that andrew got
redemption in this movie and about how
he thanked the other two spider-men in a
very very touching moment on the set so
you're going to want to stick around to
the end of this video to hear it all so
if you're new and you love spider-man
and the mcu be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos let's go watch this interview oh
absolutely yeah i mean like this is also
a role i mean you've said like if if i
hit you know 30 and i'm doing spider-man
something's wrong this is a role that
you can really grow into like do you see
yourself okay i could do the nathan
drake until i'm 50.
that quote i think has been slightly
misconstrued what i basically was trying
to say is that if i am 30 still playing
spider-man and i haven't passed on the
baton to a mars morales or a
spider-woman or something more diverse
then i would have done something wrong
in the sense of the sort of duties i
have to the character
not that like if i'm playing spider-man
in my 30s i'm like some washed up has
been that's not what i was saying only
making billion dollar movies every year
now yeah exactly
um so for me i
um
i i could see myself playing this
character into my 30s uh
i'm i'm very confident in in the films
and the project's capabilities to
succeed
and i think we have a really special
bit of material on our hands
so first things first tom holland
clarifies what he meant when he said
this quote a long time ago which is
great he doesn't mean that if he's 30
and still playing the same character
he's doing something wrong at least not
as an actor but as somebody who actually
cares about the character and about the
franchise what he meant was that if he's
still playing that character and other
people like miles morales and
spider-woman haven't come in then he's
doing a disservice to himself because he
is a fan but us as well as the other
fans but notice the last thing that he
said he said i can see myself playing
this character into my 30s and i'm very
confident in the films and project's
ability to succeed and then he said he
thinks they have a really special bit of
material on their hands this is great
news because he's talking about the
future of spider-man they just went
through an extremely special bit of
material the three spider-man on screen
live action for the very first time and
now he's saying they still have special
material left while at the same time
talking about how he thinks that
eventually the baton should be passed
down to a miles morales or a spider
woman now coincidentally olivia wilde is
set to direct a marvel spider-man film
it is currently untitled however many
people believe and rumor has it that it
is going to be a spider-woman film
following jessica drew and of course as
i've mentioned several times and as most
fans know miles morale morales
technically does exist inside of the mcu
because in spider-man homecoming we met
his uncle aaron davis aka the prowler
played by the childish gambino donald
glover who specifically mentions that he
has a nephew who of course is miles also
not to mention they dropped the miles
morales easter egg and spider-man no way
home where jamie foxx's electro says i
thought you were going to be black
there's got to be a black spider-man out
there somewhere so perhaps this is the
way that marvel studios plans to move
perhaps tom holland spider-man is going
to be sticking around for another one
two or three films hopefully another
trilogy but it looks like he is
eventually going to be passing that
baton off as he says to a different
spider-man or spider-woman which i'm
really excited to see now many of you
really loved spider-man knowing home and
in a different interview with the
hollywood reporter tom holland opened up
about two things that i really want to
talk about one he talked about how the
other two spider-men and the other two
actors really helped him and he talked
about a particular scene where he thanks
them in the film and then he talks about
andrew garfield's redemption arc in
spider-man no way home which i'll
actually talk about first because i
really love this because i really loved
andrew garfield spider-man in no way
home and i loved the fact that he
finally got his time and he finally did
get that redemption in the interview he
was asked one of the most heartwarming
aspects of no way home is the fact that
andrew is finally getting his due as
peter has the response to andrew's
performance been a source of pride for
you in which tom holland replied without
question i could not be happier for him
something i can look back on now with a
little bit of clarity and regret is that
i never called him when i took over as
spider-man had someone said to me after
my second movie that i was done and this
other kid was taking over i would have
been heartbroken so looking back i wish
i had the chance to make amends with him
but this film was our opportunity it was
not only an opportunity for him to make
peace with the character and the studio
but it was also an opportunity for me
and him to have this moment where we
realized we could share this thing the
look on his face when he saves zendaya
mj is totally genuine and i'm really
proud of him i'm really chuffed that he
got this opportunity to win back the
world and for people to be reminded that
his spider-man movies are fantastic and
brilliant in their own right now this i
absolutely
love because again i loved andrew
garfield in this movie and for tom to
say that andrew's face and his
expression when he caught mj was genuine
means that he was legitimately crying
and choked up over the fact that he
actually did get to save mj he couldn't
save gwen but he could save mj and i
think in a way he was kind of saving a
part of himself as well like in the
scene where toby is telling him that
he's amazing that's pretty meta it has
two different meanings not only is he
talking to spider-man as spider-man
making the little pun that he's amazing
hence the amazing spider-man but he's
also just toby mcguire talking to andrew
garfield saying hey dude your spider-man
was amazing your peter parker was
amazing you're amazing don't tell
yourself that your movies were bad you
are an amazing actor you were an amazing
spider-man and that's coming from the
original spider-man so i'm sure that
meant a lot to andrew garfield now the
second thing i want to talk about from
this interview is really really cool
it's where peter 1 is thanking peter 2
and peter 3. tom holland is asked in the
interview i love the moment where peter
says thank you thank you
thank you to peter 2 tobey maguire and
peter 3 andrew garfield he's obviously
saying thank you to those characters for
their help and their wisdom but i also
read it as you tom saying thank you to
toby and andrew for setting an example
and paving the way for your era as
spider-man was that in the back of your
mind at all while you filmed that
goodbye and this is what tom holland
said yeah that moment was actually
inspired by something that actually
happened we were on set shooting the
rooftop scene where i met the boys for
the first time and before one of the
takes it must have been my close-up or
something it was one that really really
required me to bring the emotion to the
shot so i went up to the two boys on the
level that they were standing and i said
to them thank you
thank you thank you for doing this thank
you for being here thank you for
elevating spider-man in the ways that
you have thank you for being so gracious
and allowing me to share this with you
thank you for taking a leap of faith and
coming back toby hadn't acted in nearly
10 years so we all embraced each other
and we were all crying because it meant
so much to us and john watts amy pascal
and the writer saw this moment between
the three of us and were like brilliant
well now we know how they're going to
say goodbye to each other so essentially
we just reshot that very real moment
between the three of us and i can't tell
you how much i absolutely love this and
i would just so
love to see some behind the scenes shots
of the three spider-men just hanging out
together and possibly crying together
like we just heard about that's kind of
all i want right now but let me know
what you think about what tom holland
said about the future of spider-man and
this touching moment between the three
spider-man actors don't forget to like
the video if you enjoyed it don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all other mcu news and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof